as a talk show host I comment about many
things in life but a particularly enjoy
mob talk why talk about the geriatric
expresso sipping psychotic killers of
organized crime and if their names a
gaudy and they're in the Gambino crime
family I have an orgasm attic verbal
frenzy because I know them I know
they're degenerates right down to the
marrow of their bonin when John Gotti
seen you was on trial for the last time
the fourth time when they stripped him
of his Teflon and he ended up doing
triple life without parole at merion in
Illinois I would critique the trial each
and every morning after the day befores
testimony and I would talk about what an
enemy of society a cretin with
chromosome damage and knuckle draggers
odd rule a musclehead this gaudy senior
was and naturally every sycophant Tony
and Lackey threw out the new york area
would call up disparage me threaten me
and tell me that I would soon be room
temperature and i would say old fart to
you and language and I can't even
describe here but you know what they
actually carried out their threats and
so an April they decided to to me up
they took out some baseball bats and
laid in wait for me to come out of my
apartment on the Lower East Side to make
my way to WABC at Madison Square Garden
and they hit me about 32 times and
rearranged my medulla and cerebellum so
that all the furniture was upstairs and
rearranged in the wrong rooms and assume
that I would learn the code of omerta I
would shut my mouth well the moment I
got out of the ER at Beth Israel I just
ratcheted it up instead of a half hour a
day or mob talk it was an hour a day and
now I talked about unsolved crimes
involving Gotti senior and Gotti junior
and that obviously caused him to pop the
top because I didn't realize he was
given an AM radio in federal prison so
he could listen to me every morning
before he would go to trial and he
ordered his son the underboss of the
Gambino crime family to whack me he said
you get little nick nick coraggio who
grew up with him in canarsie he knows
every move we know slee was going to
resist and this is the plot they stole a
yellow cab late at night so the handles
off on the inside and turn it into a
rolling coffin and assume that on one of
those mornings I would pick their cab
which had their wheelman a Gambino guy
named at Angelo Dundee boom beam
Brown or something along those lines and
the shoot of Michael you naughty and
they would go round and round the block
Joey D'Angelo looked like a cab driver
Michael Ian Adi was a killer
extraordinaire because he was an
executioner and on the sixth day that
they went round and round bingo lotto
day for them I picked their cab I jumped
in the back told Madison Square Garden
hurry up Mack said no problem sliwa and
I thought wow an english-speaking cab
driver guy when those ways going man
this is my day I can actually relax read
the newspapers prepare for the broadcast
halfway there instead of turning left
and going west he turns right to govern
and goes east and I say hey Mac turned
his hack around and all of a sudden he
was putting the pedal to the metal and I
could hear the transmission grinding and
I said hmm I don't think he's taking
this to aamco for transmission fixed and
I said hey Mac I told you turn his hack
around and then lickety-split within
seconds all of a sudden some gorilla
pops up in front of me who had been
stuffed under the dashboard he's popping
a 38 right down at my three-piece set my
lower extremities not the knife fooling
the spoon and fork and all of a sudden
he says take this you son of a bitch
pool and he fires and I could see the
fire leave the barrel of the gun didn't
feel anything and ever been shot before
so assume wow this is just a bad dream
or misfire and by the time I could come
to my senses as my heart was peepin and
I felt like Robbie robot in lost in
space you know danger mr. Robinson
danger he raises a gun fires his second
time and now I feel it the cramping the
blood is spewing all of a sudden I'm in
a panic and I immediately dive for the
door figure out dive into oncoming
traffic risk becoming a speed bump and
they knew I would do that and as I reach
for the handle and pull to yank it open
and came off from my hand and power a
third shot right through my legs like a
hot knife through butter had now been
shot three times I'm bleeding like a
sieve i'm stuffed beneath the driver
trying to avoid the head shots i'm
fighting the gun off so he can't pop two
in the back of my head and then all of a
sudden i pick up my guardian angel
walkie-talkie i say angel one Code Red
Angel one and they stop blabbering away
and it distracts the drive at Joey D
Angelo who thinks maybe it's NYPD 50 so
he
I was on the sidewalk he drives back
onto the street he makes a radical turn
going south towards the Williamsburg
Bridge and I feel a gust of wind and I
said feet don't fail me now I got
precious little energy so i used the
cushion in the back to see as if it were
a trampoline dived in the direction of
what i felt was an open window because I
felt the gust of wind luckily they had
opened the window just moments before
they had picked me up because the air
conditioner wasn't working lucky that
the AC wasn't working I bet it halfway
out the window the government panics he
realizes oh my god he's out the window
so he pulls me up by my belt he puts the
gun in my back the driver at the same
time crashes me in to park cars I
smashed me like sardines not to but they
dumped that final bullet in the back
pushed me out and figure I'm dead on
arrival and I'm sucking concrete next
thing you know they scrape me up off the
asphalt put me in the gurney put me in
the meat wagon throw me on the emergency
route of Bellevue and they start cutting
and chopping in an hour and a half will
actually hours later days later I wake
up in intensive care with every tube and
every orifice of my body the bells and
whistles I wake up slowly I see that
first face that indicates to me that I'm
alive I'm not dead and it's Ed Koch my
former nemesis the former mayor of the
city of New York who thought I was a
hemorrhoid in a red beret and I thought
I had died and gone straight to hell
without an asbestos suit when I came to
my senses I realized that was alive I
took a licking and came back taking and
let's face it wasn't my martial arts
skill that saved day or my street smarts
it was the man upstairs who decided it
wasn't I wasn't ready to be punching on
the time clock yet and going out feet
first